this is the heart of the choco-andian
region of pitunja in Ecuador it's known
for its extraordinary biodiversity and
is essential for providing much of the
capital's fresh water and food
production here we produce organic
coffee milk meat cocoa sugar bananas
loads of products that go to the city
and from there to other places around
the world
but people like Vilma say that the
region and those who live in it are
facing a powerful enemy
not far away Rusty machinery and sacks
of leftover chemicals are the telltale
signs that illegal miners have passed
through here
in addition Ecuador's government has
granted 12 mining concessions to local
and international companies and eight
more are in the works
they say they'll carry out responsible
mining that's what they've been saying
since the beginning of time from the
exploitation of oil to mining but I
think we all know the reality
apart from the Exquisite vegetation the
mountains and the hills that you see
here are rich in gold and in Copper that
is why the communities that live here
warn that all this could become one
giant mine that would contaminate and
destroy life that's why on Sunday
ecuadorians will be asked to vote in a
referendum in which they can decide
whether or not to completely ban mining
in this area as well as oil extraction
in another of Ecuador's ecological hot
spots
the yasuni national park in Ecuador's
Amazon rainforest is one of the most
biodiverse in the world
but it's also rich in oil
on Sunday's referendum ecuadorians will
essentially have to decide what's more
important exploiting Ecuador's most
important source of income or preserving
it for the good of the environment and
its inhabitants
leader of the petrol Workers Union
insists both are possible
what we are exploiting at the moment is
barely 80 hectares out of a total
hundred thousand that makes up the asuni
park that's allowed us to extract 55 000
barrels of oil a day which is nearly 1.2
billion dollars for the Ecuadorian state
a lot of money for a country already
deep in debt the question ecuadorians
must answer is what will ultimately cost
them and their environment more
Lucy in human Al Jazeera in the Andean
choco region Ecuador